it's December 2nd 2010 and the
International Federation of association
football or FIFA gathered in Switzerland
to announce which country would host the
2018 and 2022 World Cups and they had
assembled a powerful audience
here's former U.S President Bill Clinton
who was there to back the U.S bid and
here's Prince William working on behalf
of England's bid behind him is the prime
minister of the Netherlands and former
Prime Minister of Belgium who together
submitted a joint bid but even with all
this political power in one room the
fate of their countries lay in the hands
of these guys the 22 FIFA officials with
the power to pick the host they would
consider the goals for the bidding
Nations they were the masters of their
Destiny but many of these men have been
accused of abusing their power and this
was the moment they took it a step too
far 2018 FIFA World Cup ladies and
gentlemen will be organized in Russia
22 FIFA World Cup is Qatar
decision is still one of the worst
decisions made by sporting organization
it was catastrophic for feedback they've
had their whole legacies called into
question the announcement set off at
Cascade of events that rocked the world
of football and nearly broke FIFA a
rampant and deep-rooted Corruption
corruption and widespread corruption in
the interfering and money laundering how
did FIFA go from organizing one of the
most beloved sporting events in the
world to corrupting it
[Music]
red in the early 20th century football
was already super popular mainly in
Europe and South America where national
teams had begun playing each other so a
group of officials in France formed FIFA
in 1904 to oversee these competitions
and promote the sport
in 1930 inspired by the Olympics they
decided to start their own tournament
the first question was who would host it
out of FIFA's 44 member countries at the
time six placed bids to host it
FIFA's Congress made up of one
representative from each country was put
in charge of voting for a winner but
really this vote was a facade so there
was no bid contests as such it was
effectively decided Behind Closed Doors
by a bunch of commencing men eventually
FIFA awarded Uruguay the rights to host
the first World Cup and it was a Fitting
Place to do it Uruguay had just won the
last two Olympic gold medals in football
but it also agreed to pay for a lot
including the travel expenses of other
teams and share the profits with FIFA in
July 1930 13 teams came together to play
Uruguay beat Argentina in the finals and
FIFA made a solid profit mostly from
ticket sales the World Cup was a success
over the next couple of decades FIFA
decided to rotate the tournament between
Europe and South America
the World Cup wasn't a grandiose thing
back then you know there were some
upgrades to the stadiums to the existing
infrastructure and a piece of marketing
going on but the World Cup wasn't wasn't
a truly Global event that all changed
when it went on TV I am very pleased
that this country is acting as hers for
the final of the World Cup once the
whole world can watch the tournament the
host nation became much more visible
leading many more countries to want to
host one in virtually every country
football has now such a following that
no government can afford to ignore it
through the 60s and 70s FIFA's
membership started exploding by the 80s
it had close to 170 members mostly
divided into six confederations with
their own qualifying tournaments and the
organization kept getting richer take a
look at how FIFA's profits greased
deadly with almost every tournament
until Boom the 1980s that's when World
Cup sponsorships merchandise and TV
rights became worth millions
all of this money was largely controlled
by 24 officials the leaders of each
Confederation and some senior officials
like the president
this group was called the executive
committee or xco
they had the power to distribute FIFA's
money to its member countries for
building football fields holding
tournaments and establishing youth
programs varial this system about any
checks and played lots of money was
cycling though you know a development
money Kickback became almost standard
practice in certain parts of the world
FIFA leaders began using Corrupt
Practices to gain and retain power the
corruption that went on suit to the two
presidents avalandra's nakedly corrupt
and Arlington bribes that's well
documented set glass was very different
he was addicted to power there was a
cabal of nakedly corrupt committee men
within people and Mr blatter ignored
their excesses because he relied on
their support to keep himself in power
it was in this culture of corruption
that FIFA in 1964 decided to take the
vote away from Congress and give it to
exco meaning that to host a World Cup
countries only needed to win the votes
of a majority of exco just 13 of them
the fact that such a small body of and
had such a powerful position vested
among them without any real checks and
balances yeah it absolutely made corrupt
sheep part of it
FIFA's corruption wasn't a secret but
they had moved their headquarters to
Switzerland long ago and that meant
their finances couldn't really be traced
to confirm corruption
at least for another decade
the 2006 World Cup bid was the most
competitive in FIFA's history it had
previously begun accepting bids from
countries outside of Europe and South
America
it awarded hosting rights to the U.S in
94 and South Korea and Japan in 2002 for
the 2006 World Cup five countries wanted
to hosted and for good reason I think
there's a huge amount of prestige that
it brings to not just the country but
the leadership of the country it's sort
of a a step on the way towards nation
building with more and more countries
desperate for World Cup Prestige FIFA
found ways to play them off each other
the bidding countries spent millions of
dollars on a two-year Gauntlet of PR
events to impress FIFA
and try to outdo each other by promising
new stadiums hotels infrastructure and
lucrative tv offers
this became the well-known public-facing
side of the bidding process that was the
start I think where the World Cup became
really very heavily politicized when the
2006 vote came to a close exco chose
foreign
thanks to one voter abstaining at the
last moment journalists had later
revealed that Germany had bribed at
least four exco members for their votes
including the official who abstained who
was the first publicly reported incident
that revealed FIFA had another layer to
its bidding process that involved
cutting deals with XCOM members under
the table because of a lack of criteria
that governed by the World Cup was going
to go the old man who stuck on its
executive committee were whined and
dined and indulged for a significant
period of time and in some cases you
know quite handsomely renumerated
and it happened again for the 2010 World
Cup bid which South Africa won
allegations would later emerge that it
too had paid ex-co-members for their
votes this shadier side of the bid was
becoming vital to winning and in the
next two bids it would destroy the
legacy of the World Cup
in the lead-up to this announcement FIFA
had decided that the 2018 cup would be
in Europe four bidders emerged England
with its expansive infrastructure was
the heavy favor for the same reasons the
US was a favorite among five bidders for
2022.
but of course this was only part of what
it took to win a World Cup bid
the countries that did win the vote that
day were the ones who could pour the
most money into all levels of FIFA
system
[Music]
people often either look Russian you
know Rush is very much at the Forefront
of everybody's mind as long as someone
like Vladimir Putin were behind it then
they were always going to be very
competitive in that process this is
Bonita merciaris she saw the World Cup
bidding process from the inside while
working on Australia's bid that same
year they had the capacity they had the
technical capability they had the
facilities Russia pledged to spend 10
billion dollars in the use of 16
stadiums but equally important was the
fact that they stacked their bid with
Rich influential and well-connected
people the head of the Russian bid was
Igor chevalov the Russian Sports
Minister and the president of the
Russian Football Association was also
heavily involved and that they brought
in some of their oligarchs to help
support it financially such as
Abramovich what does that tell you it
tells you we've got money we've got
basically [ __ ] you money we can do what
we like and they did
ex-co-member Rafael salguero would later
admit that he agreed to accept one
million dollars for his vote from Russia
and Jack Warner allegedly received 5
million for hits
Russia was using the full weight of its
government corporations and connections
to win every layer of the vid process
just as FIFA had designed it and they
weren't the only ones the reason why I
thought Qatar was always a possibility
was this wasn't just about the World Cup
for them it was the government saying
this as an important step in their
nation building so they really really
wanted it and they had Deep Pockets at
first glance qatar's bid was a long shot
it's a fairly small country with a
football team that's never qualified for
the World Cup it was also too hot for
football temperatures could reach 50
degrees in the summer and in 2010 Qatar
only had one major city and one Stadium
big enough for a World Cup game but what
Qatar did have is some of the largest
natural gas reserves in the world with
an enormous amount of wealth all
controlled by the country's Amir Hamad
bin Khalifa altani
and they were willing to use it to win
the 2022 bit it pledged to spend an
astonishing 200 billion dollars on
infrastructure and build 12 brand new
air-conditioned stadiums a bid other
countries couldn't match and they didn't
forget about xco
British journalists would later allege
that a qatari-owned company paid Warner
around 2 million dollars for his vote
there's also allegations that Qatar made
payments to three other exco members
but Russia and guitar's advantages went
beyond wealth they were the only two
authoritarian countries in the contest
meaning they were Freer to work the
shadier side of the bid you know the
Australian World Cup that was very well
funded as well but it was all publicly
funded and every every scent was meant
to be accounted for you know maybe you
could move stuff around spreadsheets and
so on but if you're going to engage in
the dark arts you had to be very very
careful
whereas if you were coming from an
authoritarian State like Russia or like
Qatar you you can do what you like
created a bidding process that would
inevitably be won by the countries with
the most cash and the least
accountability and the thing is Russian
Qatar got away with it but the scandals
that followed nearly destroyed FIFA
allegations emerged weeks after the 2010
vote but it wasn't until 2015 that the
FBI arrested several FIFA officials in
Zurich and launched investigations into
Decades of FIFA's dealings
even though no one's been put on trial
for taking bribes from Qatar since the
vote 13 of the 22x co-voters present
that year have either been indicted or
banned from FIFA at some point
amidst these scandals ceplatter resigned
in disgrace so in 2016 in an attempt to
clean up its act FIFA gave congress the
power to vote on World Cup hosts once
again
but the 2018 World Cup in Russia went on
as planned generating record revenue for
FIFA and Qatar is predicted to do the
same are we comfortable wish the human
rights record of Qatar and Russia
are they comfortable with what Russia is
doing at the moment
that decision has been a great enabler
for both those countries it's a decision
that just doesn't stand the test of time
at all they didn't get it right then and
it's not right now
foreign
[Music]